my favorite movie from another country
[Music]
hmm
I have to choose
the foreign film started to come to
America I think my Bergman was the
answer winter light it's a Bergman film
does a beautiful job of contrasting the
Beauty and the sacred in each person
with the kind of absurd and disgusting
and animalistic in each person finally
on Alexander I think is a Bergman that
crisscrosses Fable with horror with
family stories psychological study I
think city of God was one of the first
films that I watched where it just
really inspired me to become even more
invested in just like the Artistry and
the history of film Rome at the top
actress Simone signo Ray her performance
I could feel her womanness and her
greatness her mothering and her strength
and her soul seventh Samurai by karasawa
Curacao was the seventh Samurai because
the epicness of the new Curacao is
everything between the cinematography
and also the performances life is
beautiful I don't think I've stopped
harder than when I watched that movie
Last Train to Busan it was just riveting
frightening and totally believable I'm
not even gonna lie
when I watched the movie I almost shared
a thug tear I thought they hit on a
completely different note when it came
to holding zombie genre Cold War
by Paul parowski which is not how you
say his name and another is Capernaum by
Nadine I loved Mustang
I love the square Entre new by Diane
curies Fassbender is the marriage of
Maria Braun I'm a romantic and I cried
so hard at the end of Cyrano de la Novia
my mom is Argentinian and I hadn't been
in Argentina since I was little and when
I saw it it kind of reconnected me back
to Argentina
Amor sparrows
it really gets you from the beginning
even from the opening of the film
parasite it's social commentary it's
humor great characters wrapped in one I
got to work with long Joon ho
a film called okja I've always had a
huge crush on him ever since I saw
memories of murder a man called OVA was
so life affirming Victoria to seek his
bicycle thief it awakened me to the
possibility of Cinema from all around
the world having an impact on me in a
very personal way
foreign